Maybe.
Hello, Michael.
Hello.
Hey, Michael, good afternoon.
In Michael.
How are you?
Been good, good. I've been.
Doing very well.
You see, it seems like you're pretty busy.
It's always busy here.
One sec, let me get my webcam on. Yeah, I just got back from vacation myself, so...
It's Monday, so...
Yeah.
Oh, that's nice.
Then obviously you would not like to work. So, right? You're checking on your mails, catching up on the stuff that you left behind.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's always fun to come back to about 400 emails.
Yeah, that is, that is so true.
And how was your vacation, by the way?
It was great. It was nice to get a break. Went down to the southern US, saw Tennessee and some other states.
IND.
Nice, nice. So it was like within US.
Yeah, all within the US, still a, still a 10-hour drive, but...
Wow.
Ten hours, it was kind of the road trip, right? You were like just driving, you know, having fun.
Exactly.
One thing to the next.
So, oh, that's great. So did you take your family along with you or was it like just friends?
All right, and I'm waiting. Oh, go.
I went with my fiance, so it was great. Just a nice break.
Pre.
Even better.
Yeah.
So, that sounds fun.
So, just so you know, I am messaging Sean. He's actually finishing a call with one of our clients, but he said we're good to proceed.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what T just said on the chat as well. So we'll start.
Yes.
All right, so I'm gonna share my screen and let me know when you can see it.
Alright, I see it.
Great, so welcome, Michael, to our monthly service check-in for Land Tech. We will be looking at May month's performance. Will the agenda item stay the same? We'll go through the highlights, performance analysis, holiday schedule. Bill the 2026, team GPS, way forward, and then meeting minutes.
Our lights for last month is we need research on the root cause for SQL alerts for multiple clients. He is providing valuable insight on security coach feature integration for cross-key Engineering and helping the team with the escalate the tickets.
Anything that you want to add to this, Michael?
I will say he's part of this overlays into this month, but he's been a massive asset. We're doing an Entra and Intune migration for one of our customers away from an on-prem setup, and he's been very helpful in getting everything functional and configuring it properly.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Now, no, that's music to our ears. Thank you so much for sharing that, Michael. Moving on, as per the performance, I see that in his numbers as well, because from last couple of weeks, you know, his utilization was like 100%. So he was pretty busy. And that's why you see that spike in the month of May.
Yes.
after the dip in April, that now it's closing on 75% benchmark score. The rest ticket closure rate is 100%, and on an average from May till Feb till May, it's 73%. Top call drivers being project and migration internal escalated tickets, server and phishing alerts.
All right, anything that you want to add before we go on to the next one?
No, it all looks good.
Great. Next up, as per the holiday schedule, it's July 3rd. So do you want him to be working?
We will actually, let me look, I believe we are actually closed, so he does not need to work for July 3rd.
OK, great. I'll let him know so that he's not working on that day, and if he requests any more PDO, let you know. OK.
Absolutely.
Great, build it. I know you guys are registered, so we will see Sean during the event. Okay, I think you're not coming, right?
Uh, no, unfortunately I couldn't make it.
Yeah, we'll miss you, but I'm sure Sean will give you all the great stuff that he will witness.
Oh.
Okay, AI by Design will be part of our Build It this year. So on the last day, August 5th, we'll have AI by Design.
The.
Next up, we have Team GPS, which we already know. Way forward remain the same. We need will continue to.
deliver on what he has committed and he is setting up the bar so high that it's difficult for the rest of the team to even catch up. So we'll continue to do the same rest from ITBD side, we are committed to deliver the best product possible and we are ready to support any additional needs that we come.
This year and next year.
Okay.
All right.
With this, that's pretty much it for this month. I'm going to stop sharing my screen and over to you, Michael, for any questions, concerns, or feedback for us.
Honestly, Vineet's done an excellent job. Especially, I'm very impressed recently with this migration. It's one of our smaller clients, DJI, but he's more or less spearheaded bringing them onto Intune and getting all their devices enrolled, making sure everything syncs from the local.
Mhm.
And yeah, he's been very good in explaining it and also showing some of our team members and getting them more acquainted with it all. But no complaints.
Awesome. I keep on saying this. I wish we could clone Vineet and give you maybe.
Yeah.
Ten or hundreds of needs, right?
With AI, you never know.
Yeah.
Nothing is impossible, right? That's how AI have changed our mindset. Well, thank you so much for your time today, Michael. Before we wrap it up, Manish, Andy, anything from your end?
I.
I just want to thank Michael for the positive feedback. And Michael, other than Vineet, any suggestions or feedback upon your overall experience with ITBD?
Um...
Any challenges, any suggestions?
Not at this time, honestly. It's been very positive recently and things have been working well.
Thank you, thank you, Michael.
OK, perfect. Thank you, Andy. Manish.
Hi, Michael. First of all, I apologize. I'm not able to turn on my webcam at this point of time. Same thing as Andy mentioned. I really appreciate your kind words for Vinit's performance. I know that he deserves it, but we need to
We need someone like you who appreciates it as well. So I hope things are going to stay the same and we will be getting some more magical words from your side. Thank you.
Okay, thank you, Manish. Well, that's pretty much it from my side for this month. Michael, we'll connect with you next month. Till then, if you have any questions or concerns, feel free to reach out. And thanks so much for your time today. Have a good one. Take care.
Excellent. Thank you all.
Thank you, Michael. Bye-bye.
Thank you. Bye bye.
Thank you.
All right, bye-bye.